as all institutions governments health
systems economies but the corona virus
pandemic is most of all testing people
this is not only an unprecedent of
challenges to our health care systems
but also a major shock to our economies
I am convinced that the European Union
can withstand this shock but each member
states needs to live up to its full
responsibility and the European Union as
a whole needs to be determined
coordinated coordinated and United in a
pandemic scientific based guidance is
essential to help plot the best course
of action
yesterday together with Commissioner
Stella Collier Cledus I launched a board
of outstanding scientists biologists
epidemiologists to assess the ongoing
situation and help us develop the most
effective responsive responses our goal
is to develop guidelines and
evidence-based strategies to deal with
the spread of the virus we are just at
the beginning every member state even
those who have very low numbers today
all of us have to know and to understand
this is not possible to stop the
violence but it is possible and of
utmost importance to slow down the
spread of the virus that is doable and
you've seen many measures like schools
and universities are being closed events
are canceled we just slowed down the
public life this should give our health
care systems our nurses and our doctors
the intensive care units the time and
the space they need to cope with a
search of new patient as the virus
spreads on
the Commissioner is also taking all
necessary steps to ensure an adequate
supply of protective equipment across
Europe commissioner Berto is in close
contact with the producers of such
equipment we assess the stocks we work
on scaling up their capacity rapidly and
here I want to be very clear the single
market market market has to function it
is not good when Member States take
unilateral action because it always
causes a domino effect and that prevents
the urgently needed equipment from
reaching the patients from reaching
hospitals and the medical personnel and
ultimately it amounts to reintroducing
internal borders at a time when
solidarity between member states is
needed on this matter I have been in
very close contact with Germany with
France and with other member states and
I'm happy to report that they are
willing to adapt their national measures
as we requested in the last few hours
we've seen travel bans and controls
being put in place in a number of member
states of course we all want to protect
our citizens from the spread of the
virus so let's look together at how we
can do that and how we can do it most
effectively certain controls may be
justified but general travel bans are
not seen as being the most effective by
the World Health Organization moreover
they have a strong social and economic
impact they disrupt people's lives and
business across the borders in other
words any measure that is taken must be
proportionate what we can do and what we
should do is to carry out how screening
measures this can be taken at external
borders or they can be taken an internal
borders and as well within the territory
of the Member States
and this is why we propose to have EU
guidelines for health screening at the
borders commissioner Johansson will
present these today to the ministers at
the justice and Home Affairs Council
just once again in general for any
measure to be effective they need to be
coordinated at EU level member states
especially neighboring ones need to work
very closely together in this way and
it's the only way we can make sure that
our citizens receive the health care
that they need immediately wherever they
are at the moment this was strongly the
Health part I want to turn to the
economic sector we all know that the
virus is not only dangerous for our
health but it is also hitting our
economies it is a major shock for the
global and for the European economy and
we have to take decisive and bold
actions now and this on all different
levels the shock is temporary but we
must work together to ensure that it is
as short and as limited as possible and
it does not create permanent damage to
our economies and therefore member
states should be encouraged and they
should feel comfortable to take all the
necessary measures to support the most
affected sectors for example tourism for
example transport or retail just to name
some and they should be encouraged and
they should feel comfortable to take all
the necessary measures they need to
support people for example through short
time work schemes or other effective
measures for this to happen that is
giving the Member States reassurance we
at the European level are providing man
See Mom flexibility flexibility on state
aid and executive vice president
Margaret West here will present this in
detail and flexibility within the
stability or growth pact executive vice
president vitae stone breakfast will
tell you more about this in a moment in
this moment flexible EU state aid rules
enabled States member states to take
swift action to support companies and
citizens for example yesterday the
Commission approved within hours the
first request coming from Denmark to
compensate companies for cancellation of
events with a large number of
participants the serious disturbance to
the Italian economy created by the
coronavirus will lead the Commission to
authorize wide ranges of state aid
measures to remedy this situation
alongside these overarching
macroeconomic measures the Commission
has also adopted today proposals to
provide liquidity into our economy we're
setting up a 37 billion euros Corona
response investment initiative to grant
support to the healthcare sector to the
labour market to support SMEs from
always factored sectors furthermore the
EU budget will deploy its existing
instruments to support small and medium
enterprises with liquidity complementing
thus the measures taken at a national
level give you some examples the
European investment will guarantee for
example 8 billion euros in euros in
loans for 100,000 SMEs and small
mid-caps
or as you already know the Commission's
proposal to enable Airlines to keep the
airport slots even if they do not
operate flights in those slots because
of the declining traffic this temporary
measure will help both our
aviation industry and the environment it
will help decrease emissions by avoiding
the so-called ghost flights when
airlines fly almost empty Plains simply
to keep best Lots the measures announced
today deal with the situation of today
this is an important economic package
but we have to acknowledge that the
situation is evolving very fast we stand
ready to do more as the situation
evolves we will do whatever is necessary
to support the Europeans and the
European economy lemis Rivoli kiss OTT
MOC correspondence situation do jewelry
society pocket economic apart on menu
Devon rockin ethical a situation a
veloute repeat more news from prayer
affair please move on to Suki NSSL put
certain nearly Java para el economic
European the Hyuga [ __ ] the hurting
Muslims in Turkish Litton of the actual
as it was shown thus is Invictus packet
funeral of apparel shop a beginner de
Medici Lara for industry enviable right
we're - - we went honest nuclear hunter
named the or appear on your Peshawar
shaft to study thank you mystic thank
you very much
the outbreak of the Kovach 19 as you
just heard our president say it affects
every one of us so our goal together is
to work together to bring all of
Europe's resources to tackle this
unprecedented situation it is both lives
and livelihoods that are at stake
business was all over Europe and in
particular smaller ones are struggling
with the effects of the actions that
governments have a hat to take to slow
down the spread of the virus so the
Commission will work quickly and
decisively to help governments use
resources to help citizens and
businesses our goal is here to make sure
that businesses have the liquidity they
need to keep operating and to make sure
that the support reaches the companies
that needs it and support for our
businesses in one member state
Muhsin undermine the unity that Europe
needs a unity that will take us through
the crisis we have to be able to rely on
the European single market to help our
economies weather this outbreak and to
bounce back strongly afterwards many
member states are taking action we will
work closely and quickly with them to
provide the support which the economy
needs and in a way that limits harm to
the single market a part of that we will
give advice and we will share templates
of the schemes that works well there are
many ways that governments can help
without needing state aides approval
they can give all businesses throughout
the economy a breathing space to help
them cope providing wage subsidies
suspending corporate tax payments or the
payments of v80 but we will need to do
more and the European rules on state aid
they enables governments to take
effective action to name just three
examples on how to compensate for
damages and to provide liquidity for
companies first
in some sectors that be tourism
transport hotels restaurants while they
are hit especially hard so we are
working with governments to put in place
schemes that compensate sectors for the
damages they have suffered because of
the covitz 19 outbreak Wednesday we
received the first notification of state
aid to tackle the effects of the curve
19 outbreak the Danish government
submitted its plans to compensate
companies that had to cancel events with
more than a thousand people and we
signed off with those plans within 24
hours and we will work just as fast with
any other member states that want to
introduce schemes that compensate
businesses for the damages with the
kovat 19 outbreak courses of course
governments can also help individuals
directly this doesn't need state aid
approval either for instance it may be
that they want to reimburse people for
tickets to cancelled events the second
example is that our sale rules enable
governments to put in place schemes that
gives small and medium-sized companies
the urgent liquidity that they need
already 9 member states have that sort
of scheme in place and we will work with
others would like to do the same or to
increase the budgets of existing schemes
my third example has to do with banks
because our economy's ability to weather
such an unprecedented situation will
also depend on banks and their readiness
to lend and some governments may want to
use banks as a channel for support of
the economy including small and medium
sized businesses we will work with
governments on this today more than a
decade after the financial crisis
European banks they are strong
and more resilient if need be in the
coming weeks and months we do have the
rules in place to enable governments to
ensure that banks have adequate
liquidity to lend to their customers the
situation we're dealing with is changing
fast there is every possibility there's
a high risk that the strain on our
economy will grow governments may need
to give state aid at a much larger scale
and our rules allow for wide-ranging
support throughout the economy in member
states that are facing serious
disturbances of their economy as I
already said Tuesday in this press room
this is the case in Italy and the
situation in more and more member states
is going in the same direction so we're
keeping a very close watch on the
situation in all Member States and
staying in close contact with
governments and we are ready to respond
as with it in 2008 at the time of the
financial crisis at that time the
Commission adopted a temporary framework
guiding Member States as to how to use
state to help stabilize the European
economy while protecting the single
market and we are now working on a new
framework so that we have it ready if it
becomes necessary what matters right now
is that we are prepared to move fast and
this is why we have put in place all the
procedures that we need to deal with new
state aid very fast and that includes a
hotline that is open seven days a week
for public authorities to raise
questions to ask for advice to ask for a
template in order to give aid to cope
with the effects of the curve 19
outbreak the European Commission will
contain
you to provide the necessary support to
governments and to citizens thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen good
afternoon let's be clear that this is
first and foremost health emergency
which are tackling with all possible
measures the well-being of the people is
our absolute priority
we commend Member States authorities for
taking courageous and far-reaching
measures to contain these words and we
also need full solidarity with those
affected around Europe we are all in
this together and we know that this
health emergency will have a significant
economic impact our job is also to make
sure that we respond in a most effective
way possible to support people and the
economy our economies are fundamentally
solid and robust enough to withstand
this temporary shock we have also tools
at our disposal we will use them fully
and without hesitation to to step in
step with the situation as it devolves
one of our top priorities today is to
make sure that our companies how also
liquidities I need and that jobs and
incomes of affected workers are
protected that applies to Italy the
first countries at was hit and of course
to all other countries in the EU the
Commission will support countries that
use full flexibility in the stability
and growth pact at these times of need
this allows our countries to implement
the urgent measures needed to contain
the outbreak and mitigate its negative
social and economic impact the unusual
events Clause can accommodate
exceptional Spain spending to contain
the virus outbreak this includes
healthcare expenditure and relief
measures for businesses and workers
countries can carry out immediate
containment measures to provide medical
equipment
increase hospital capacity civil
protection measures and information
campaigns spending can also be directed
towards providing support to workers and
the self-employed and the companies that
are most affected especially SMEs in
sectors such as tourism transport
especially aviation retail and catering
the Commission stands ready to activate
the general accept laws to accommodate a
more general fiscal policy support this
Clause would in cooperation with a
council suspend the fiscal adjustment
recommended by the council in case of a
severe economic downturn in the euro
area or EU as a whole in addition to
health affected businesses will deploy 1
billion euros of EU budget guarantee to
provide up to 8 billion euros in
liquidity to at least 100,000 SMEs
effective companies will also be able to
delay the payment on their existing
loans today I am calling on the European
Investment Bank and the European Bank of
Reconstruction and Development to
refocus their activities and to take
immediate measures to support European
businesses finally it is essential that
banks continue providing liquidity to
the economy the European Central Bank
announced yesterday measures that will
support bank lending to companies
affected the most by the spread of the
virus and provide immediate liquidity to
the system you binding supervisors how
encourage national authorities to make
full use of the available flexibility
that can provide significant capital
relief to banks to support the economy
well yes these are challenging times but
by taking the right steps at the right
time we will overcome this shock we are
all in this together and we will act in
our common European interest thank you
thank you very much we will now take
some questions and ask for the floor
I believe in German
I know [ __ ] and I get Unicron today an
Akkadian eggs IDF Brussels and Africa
and the president in in Deutsch if I may
how president in the Bundesliga Omar
Khadr anger cuneta see Tottenham on big
rancidity Gifford under mcleach tacna
mocking the conduct as Emir shouldn't
muffin then they should go foggy tough
on food inch tablet it's packed us UN's
fighter hug of Avoyelles easy hair
strand ste omitted certain miss keikain
under a bed net export for Hong Kong
analyzer stops on trans control so yes
in Fagin is yet reached if guns and
Schloss on 200 on metallic shaft
Oliver shafts understood when canal
undies and guises over the Bundesliga
but unlimited slender gets star
capacitor of often which bring a metal
stand on the verge of decline on metal
Anand renamed to student now indeed guys
200 after European Commission
there's the Alan Milliken flexibility
ons instrumental notes um Dean MIT which
started in working such that India and
China and father was the the out for but
ransom and get fewer merits in Ezra's
material was linked annuity minutest but
Java is Franz formulas 50s novel simmer
unfortunately thus limited statins and
public official tom was hardly often
marked was for huntin on 308 happened as
the snitch mere invite out there in her
house in direct lender exported vote a
buffoons in a happy in herbal patient
onion is as rich dish thus Jesus
material of his muscles Endora by admin
spirit isn't
ganzfeld Indian gesundheit sec rock
apart we hadn't taught in war as
unnoticed in East Odessa Pam via MIDI
military language bottom the Sierra
alpha Bush tomorrow and person does the
smart Alveston have a go past harm yet
da him come were assigned must fight in
partying in income horizontally out
stone on Elsa on just three the person
islands is outside investors fee of the
operation in May
I'm for the senton a new statement
contact yet since on easy to understand
we can see me applaud it's Ian vole
Milton we omit baroque artists and
Indonesian album Dmitrich nella of
pudzian conversa production of American
won't does via instant indication onion
and coordinators have on being harmed as
we can obviously pepper flaking
affiliates in the zone tight sector we
conveyed us inaudible patient on your
hairstyle with your active two questions
as well the Fed one president if you
could clarify this 37 billion in liquid
the assistant will it included 25
billion that you already announced and
also if this is also like reusing
reprogramming funds that are not ready
there or is there some new money so as
we as we call it and also do you
yourself said and also vice president
were staggered I just are ready to to
activate new plants or to mobilize more
funds or more Messrs and I would like to
know what is your assessment of the
economic situation right now because
yesterday we saw the worst session ever
in the markets many sectors are being
affected like never before
many workers in Brussels as worth going
are working from home so whatever you
need to see to activate more programs
are more measures so for the first
question
indeed we stepped up because the
situation requires it as we see it right
now so we stepped up with the amount
that is mobilized it is basically I
would call it sleeping money that member
states couldn't use anymore so it comes
from structural front envelopes but it's
we enable this sleeping money to be
active now to be directed immediately
into new sectors where normally it
couldn't go so it trickles down
immediately to the SME to the healthcare
sectors to the labor market for example
so we free money that otherwise wouldn't
have been used right now at the
situation is asking for it they
we'll be a technical briefing afterwards
immediately to these topics on the
question on on how to assess the
situation as as in your question things
are changing very fast as we looked at
things this morning it is obvious that
Italy is in the most severe situation
also when it comes to the economy we
have based our decisions on the article
107 to be for Italy and 107 3 B and it's
our expectation that more and more
countries will come into a situation
where measures can be assessed under 107
3 B this is not a checklist this is a
horizontal assessment but as I said it
is likely that more and more country
will come into this category we will
have a temporary framework ready to be
used both in countries in Europe in
regions and of course all over Europe if
we will get into this situation within
the coming days and weeks
he's Sam Fleming from the Financial
Times I had a question for executive
vice president Dombrowski's
yesterday christine lagarde said that
she was seeing a stimulus an aggregated
stimulus of around 27 billion euros
suggesting this was going to be
inadequate compared with the crisis now
faced and that she was concerned about a
complacent attitude when it came to
fiscal policy I wondered if you could
give us your estimate of looking at the
aggregate responses you're seeing how
large a fiscal stimulus are expecting
across the as across the block and
indeed does the Commission have a
recommendation when it comes to how
larger an aggregate stimulus you think
will be needed for example the package
back in 2008 was around I think 1.5
percent of GDP do you have a similar
recommendation now thank you well in
current circumstances I wouldn't be
talking so much about fiscal stimulus
rather about crisis response because
what we need now we need to use
flexibility within EU fiscal rules to
allow member states to fully respond to
the crisis - that was a medical
emergency - how all the necessary
medical financing and to support our
companies and people which will be
affected by economic consequences of
this crisis and by working together with
member states to ensure that this that
this crisis response can be fully
financed it in itself will provide well
substantial it will come at substantial
fiscal cost so in this sense one can say
it's in itself will provide substantial
fiscal stimulus so that's our first task
and as we outlined in our communication
we have different policy tools at our
disposal
starting from unusual event clause and
English general escape clause
and we stand ready to use those clauses
and measures as situation evolves to
ensure that Member States can
effectively respond to the crisis also
in a fiscal from fiscal point of view
thank you very much away from Politico I
have two quick questions for present
frontline first of all some of the
proposals you're making for example with
the investments require the European
Parliament to vote in plenary have you
been in touch with presidents are solely
to see whether it is feasible for them
to come back and to hold these votes and
do you have a plan B in case they can't
how your proposals would actually be
implemented without a vote and second
yesterday you sent a message to
Commission staffers about how you would
be operating from now on during this
crisis do you have an estimate of how
many staffers are considered essential
and would still be coming in and how
many are concerned non-essential and
would be staying home thank you for
starting with the second question so
there there is a definition I think that
we can give you a tentative numbers
later on which I do not have in my try
now don't underestimate staying home
means work from home so unfortunately
this is a fact that I know and it might
for some be more difficult to work from
home because I know of by my own
experience that if you have children
then you have really to be flexible to
manage all that but I think it's the
right thing now to do to have this
separation Tim 18b with the critical
staff and all the others to do the work
from telework from home a big thing to
to our technicians that enable this this
home teleworking within a very very
short time so this is very good I'm in
constant contact with presidents a
solely and therefore I know that he will
do with the
European Parliament everything to make
sure that the decision-making process is
understood and can keep on going because
we are all aware we're in the middle of
a deep crisis we need action now we need
decisions now and I'm very pleased by
all the positive responses I get from
the members of parliament by phone calls
or by emails supporting us backing us
with these bold actions so this is very
good we've all understood it's time now
to be united and to move forward yes
okay
the export ban on almani
requisitioned ignominy conferencing with
avidity PE the palanca they preferred a
diamond as Moscow Queens on the
proscenium ukeleleman era a magnificent
someone decree or maternity clothes the
exceptional polity level measure become
politics Antipas his aunt about convey
equal to confidence about what reforms
well indeed they would propose bit
different so the French setting was
better it was more convenient and the
German export ban had the problem that
which it is fine both country sees
desktops this is fine and had an
overview over that stuff this is
absolutely okay without any question but
important is to introduce a possibility
that this material goes right now that
we do not sit on our stocks but the
material goes right now into the
healthcare sector and the health care
sector of the European Union for example
masks - they have to be targeted led
into the the healthcare sectors
hospitals this was more difficult in the
German proposal therefore we worked with
them since the last days and you're
right that you said till the last moment
that it was not enough
today in this morning we managed to have
the final agreement they will adopt
actually I think they adopt right now as
we are speaking that was necessary I
think this is good and now we have
clarified the situation there was a lot
of goodwill the intention was to keep
the material here because we need it
desperately but of course share it in
the health care sector okay
for committee president don't block
escapes actually I would like to
understand a little bit better what do
you mean by full flexibility of the
stability and growth pact because you
were also mentioning the recommendations
for the adjustment does it mean that
actually the countries should care less
about all these rules they are supposed
to follow and does it mean that
everything is going to be well older the
measures for health care systems and
companies are going to be exempt from
the structural effort and what about the
headline deficit where will be your
evaluation here thank you well indeed
when assessing a crisis response of
member states rotates important our
standard currently we are dealing with
sudden but hopefully temporary shock to
the economy so member states need to
respond
it will require significant amounts of
money but by its nature by and large
it's going to be a one of expenditure
and as such to respond to your question
indeed it means that it can be excluded
from calculations of structural balances
of member states of course we will need
to see you know the exact expenditure
but as a general direction is clear so
indeed at something which we're going to
use we have a possibility as European
Commission to use so-called margin of
discretion when determining fiscal
effort by EU Member States it's also
reflected in our today's communication
and as a last resort also how general
escape clause in a case of severe
economic downturn in the euro area or EU
as a whole so and what we are making
clear in today's communications that we
are ready to use all this toolkit as
situation evolves to allow member states
to effectively respond to the crisis so
not
you
you
morning Allah watering chronicity just a
couple of questions if I may
the first one is that the head of state
of Italy Matala said that the European
Union should aid Italy and not put
obstacles it was referring to Madame
Lagarde press conference of yesterday I
wonder if the European Union is ready to
help Italy and to vice-president
Dombrowski's
if I may are you ready to exclude all
the expenses necessary to tackle the
coronavirus emergency not just one
affects an expenditure which is been by
its nature excluded from the calculation
of the structural deficit but also
expensive which might prove to be
structural for example if you if you
need to hire health you can fire them
after the emergency are you ready to
explode also this kind of expenses from
the calculation of the deficit thank you
we are absolutely ready to help
Italy with whatever is necessary this is
of utmost importance this country is
severely hit by coronavirus and we all
know that they need help right now so
whatever is necessary we support
whatever they need we will answer and we
know that they are also like many other
member states hit by the crisis that
follows coronavirus so for all of us
it's very clear that the next one can be
another member state we set an example
right now to help the Italian people to
help the Italian government and the the
Italian country as a unity because this
is for us helping the European Union -
we are all in this moment Italians - the
second question I can reiterate once
again that we are ready to take
all necessary measures use all
flexibility as foreseen in stability and
growth pact to allow member states to
effectively to respond to that crisis so
and this is a general approach spirit
with which we'll be approaching member
states response and specific requests of
member states I cannot now go into
details on each specific request of each
specific item which may come but I think
our general response is very clear good
day casita from bar I have a state aid
question and I have a competition
question commissioner Vesta could you
perhaps just clarify if this if these
measures these framework for for state
aid requests is this a special
instrument or is this a is this a more
general tool where you would be dealing
with requests on an ad hoc basis if it
is general I was wondering if there's a
question of timing is it is it an
open-ended tool or is it for a period of
time and how does it compare to to the
tool that was used in the banking crisis
and the competition question is is this
can you confirm whether as a result of
the virus the the DG compass you know is
perhaps looking at certain sectors
specifically to detect price gouging or
in general any anti-competitive
practices thank you
we do a number of different things right
now I said we have a specific dedicated
phone number it is man's all hours of
the day or days of the week and here we
can do a number of things we can provide
comfort for schemes for instance for
damages cost if you have to cancel your
events so that you can get compensation
for your damages that you need liquidity
if you are small and medium sized
businesses but also if specific larger
businesses are in need of our support
that could be an airline that can be
other businesses which are particularly
hard-hit here we can do also individual
measures and with the same expedite
manner as said the first one decision we
took was within 24 hours and I think
it's also important here to see that we
used an illegal basis that allows us to
escape the one time last time principle
which means that also businesses that
have had support within the last ten
years can be eligible for support if
need be in this special situation what
we are preparing right now and what we
will put in effect if Miss Sarah is a
temporary framework based on the article
107 3 B it was the same thing that was
used during the financial crisis back
then it was changed several times in
order to stay fit for purpose actually
it's the legal basis still for the
banking communication that we also may
have to use in this very specific
situation so we're preparing it as sort
of a a more generalized access for
member states to know all the things
that will be available if larger parts
of the Union and not just Italy where we
use these legal bases right now that you
can have sort of a more generalized
approach so that you don't have to work
specifically from one country to the
next country but can keep the pace and
the speed because this is exactly what
is needed right now
for businesses small as well as large to
have the necessary comforts that the
member states where they are stand ready
to help them through the crisis in order
to do what also others addressed just
now being able to bounce back once the
crisis is the health crisis seems to be
over and we can rely on the single
market to be one of the essentials tools
to be able to do that radio spaniel
hacer Jimmy reservoir C de facto una
FATA in suspension shoppers attempt over
the back to the stability is compiled on
pecan cream color back to the stability
tempo Airmen response discovered on
Towanda New Deal convoy Deep Ecology
Tamamo
la capacity officially recording la
capacity doe
dam Bastille to ski surah nisa Sarah
Porter phone Okolona Veeru young growth
pact has an enormous breathing space and
we never used it to the full extent and
that's what we're doing now we take in a
deep deep deep breath and using all the
space we have with the flexibility so
indeed so we are not suspending the
stability and growth pact we are using
flexibility which is there in stability
and growth pact but what I wanted to
reiterate once again so in current
circumstances we are faced with a sudden
shock primarily coming from measures
member states are taking to contains a
health emergency and hopefully we're
dealing with a temporary shock so we
need to finance this crisis response but
what is important that we at this time
need to provide all the necessary
liquidity to our companies especially
Assamese we need to support
our people so to deal with a social
impact to avoid as a situation where
this temporary shock becomes with a more
negative lasting effects on the economy
because if in this situation companies
will start to go out of business or
start to lose productive capacity of our
economy and this effects of economy may
turn out more lasting so so that's why
we are emphasizing so much this need to
support our companies need to support
our estimates not to lose the productive
capacity of the economy and that's why
we're using flexibility both within
stability and growth pact and both
within our state a rose merci beaucoup
don't miss your schedule is a cutie from
past format no orbiting technique on the
records feel a difference anymore you
pack a Gita book deals on
messy